buffer capacity refers to the amount of
acid or base a buffer can neutralize
before the ph changes by a large amount
an increased buffer capacity means an
increased amount of acid are based
neutralized before the ph changes
dramatically
let's compare two buffers buffer
solution 1 and buffer solution 2 and see
which one has the higher buffer capacity
buffer solution 1 has a concentration of
acetic acid of 0.250 molar and a
concentration of acetate anion also
0.250 molar buffer solution 2 also
consists of acetic acid and the acetate
anion however in this case both
concentrations are
0.0250 molar so buffer solution 1 has a
higher concentration of both acetic acid
and the acetate anion let's calculate
the initial ph of both buffer solutions
using the henderson-hasselbach equation
in the henderson-hasselbalch equation
the ph of the solution is equal to the
pka of the weak acid which for both
buffers is acetic acid plus the log of
the concentration of the conjugate based
divided by the concentration of the weak
acid in this case the conjugate base is
the acetate anion so the concentration
of the acetate anion divided by the
concentration of acetic acid for buffer
solution number one the concentration of
the acetate anion is equal to the
concentration of acetic acid therefore
the ratio of their concentrations is
equal to one
and it's the same idea for buffer
solution number two the concentration of
the acetate anion is equal to the
concentration of acetic acid therefore
the ratio of their concentrations is
also equal to one for buffer two
since the ratio of the concentrations is
equal to one the log of one is equal to
zero
and the pka value of acetic acid at 25
degrees celsius is equal to
4.74
so the ph of both buffer solutions is
equal to 4.74 plus 0 or just 4.74
so we're starting with two buffer
solutions each at a ph of 4.74
and to those buffer solutions we're
going to add
.0200 moles of hydroxide anions
and by calculating the ph change after
adding the hydroxide anions we'll be
able to see which buffer has the higher
buffer capacity the added hydroxide
anions will be neutralized by the weak
acid that's present in the buffer system
so that's acetic acid so acetic acid is
going to react with the hydroxide anions
and to make the math easier we're going
to assume that the total volume of the
buffer solutions is equal to 1 liter
both before and after the addition of
the base
so if the total volume of the solution
is 1 liter and the concentration of
acetic acid is equal to 0.250 molar in
buffer 1 that means there's 0.250 moles
of acetic acid in the buffer so 0.250
moles of acetic acid will react with the
.0200 moles of hydroxide anions that
we're adding to buffer solution 1.
let's calculate the ph of buffer
solution 1 after the addition of the
hydroxide anions the hydroxide anions
react with acetic acid to form water and
the acetate anion in buffer solution 1
the initial moles of both acetic acid
and the acetate anion are both 0.250
and to that buffer solution we're adding
.0200 moles of hydroxide anions to help
us find the final moles of acetic acid
and the acetate anion we're going to use
an icf table where i is the initial
amount of moles c is the change in moles
and f is the final amount of moles
for this reaction hydroxide anions are
the limiting reactant so we're going to
use up all of the .020
moles of hydroxide anions and we're left
with nothing since the mole ratio of
hydroxide anions to acetic acid is a one
to one mole ratio we're also going to
use up point .0200
moles of acetic acid which leaves us
with 0.230 moles of acetic acid
and for the acetate anion there's also a
coefficient of 1 in the balanced
equation so for losing
.0200 moles for the reactants we're
gaining
0.0200 moles for the acetate anion which
gives us a final amount of moles of the
acetate anion of
0.270 now that we have our final moles
we're ready to calculate the ph of the
buffer solution so the ph is equal to
the pka value which for acetic acid is
4.74
plus the log of the ratio of the
concentrations and we could put in the
concentrations but since concentration
or molarity is equal to moles divided by
liters a ratio of the concentrations
would just have the volume cancel out
because it's the same for both our
conjugate base and our weak acid so a
ratio of the moles is the same thing as
a ratio of the concentrations in the
henderson-hasselbalch equation and we
can get our moles directly from our icf
table so the moles of the acetate anion
are equal to 0.270
and the moles of acetic acid is equal to
0.230
and when we solve for the ph we find the
ph of the solution is equal to 4.8
so buffer 1 started at a ph of 4.74 and
after the addition of the hydroxide
anions the ph rose a little bit to 4.81
however that's a relatively small change
in the ph
so buffer 1 did a pretty good job of
resisting a large change in ph
next let's calculate the ph of buffer 2
after the addition of the hydroxide
anions so the initial moles of acetic
acid in buffer two is equal to point
zero two five zero moles which is the
same number of moles as the acetate
anion so point zero two five zero and
the hydroxide anions that we add are is
equal to point zero two zero zero moles
once again hydroxide anions are the
limiting reactants so all the hydroxide
anions are used up and we're left with
zero moles since the mole ratio of
hydroxide anions to acetic acid is one
to one we use up the same amount of
acetic acid point zero two zero zero
moles and we're left with point zero
zero five zero moles of acetic acid
after the neutralization
and since there's a one as a coefficient
in front of the acetate anion the
acetate anion is going to gain
0.0200 moles for a final moles of 0.0450
next we can calculate the ph of the
solution using the henderson-hasselbalch
equation so the ph is equal to the pka
value of acetic acid of 4.74
plus the log of the concentration of the
conjugate base divided by the
concentration of the weak acid and since
we can substitute in moles for that we
can grab those from our icf table and
plug in the moles of acetate and the
moles of acetic acid and then solve for
the ph
when we solve for the ph we find that
the ph of buffer solution 2 is equal to
5.69
so buffer solution 2 started at a ph of
4.74 and after the addition of the
hydroxide anions the ph rose to 5.69
that's a relatively large increase in
the ph of the solution
so going back to buffer solution 1 the
initial ph was 4.74 and the ph rose to
4.81 upon the addition of the base
for buffer solution 2 we started at 4.74
and the ph rose to 5.69
therefore buffer solution 1 had a higher
capacity to neutralize the added base
and so we say that buffer solution 1 has
the higher buffer capacity
and since buffer solution 2 had the more
dramatic change in ph upon the addition
of the same amount of bass buffer 2 has
a decreased capacity to neutralize the
bass compared to buffer one so we say
that buffer two has a decreased buffer
capacity remember that the only
difference between these two buffers was
that buffer one had a higher
concentration of acetic acid and the
acetate anion therefore the higher the
concentration of the weak acid and the
conjugate base the higher the buffer
capacity
we just looked at two buffer solutions
in which the concentrations of weak acid
and conjugate base were equal however a
buffer solution doesn't have to start
with equal concentrations of the weak
acid and its conjugate base
for example when the concentration of
weak acid is greater than the
concentration of conjugate base the
buffer has a higher capacity for added
base than added acid
and when the concentration of conjugate
base is greater than the concentration
of weak acid the buffer has a higher
capacity for added acid than added base
as an example let's think about blood
which has a ph of 7.4 the major buffer
system used to control the ph of blood
is the carbonic acid bicarbonate buffer
system in blood the concentration of
bicarbonate is greater than the
concentration of carbonic acid and since
bicarbonate is the conjugate base to
carbonic acid the concentration of the
conjugate base is greater than the
concentration of the weak acid and
therefore
the buffer system has a higher capacity
for added acid than added base
the reason why the buffer system needs
to have a higher capacity for added acid
is because the products of metabolism
that enter the bloodstream are mostly
acidic and therefore the bicarbonate
anion can react with those acidic
products and neutralize them
therefore the buffer system is able to
resist large changes to the ph of blood